now ukraine's president zielenski has
called wednesday's russian airstrike on
a children's hospital and maternity ward
in mariopo a atrocity now this attack
and the chilling scenes from its
aftermath can only increase pressure on
western allies to help ukraine on
wednesday the eu added 160 more russian
oligarchs to its blacklist as it
tightened sanctions but despite
zelinski's pleas german chancellor olaf
schultz has said that fighter jets will
not be part of the assistance germany is
providing he maintained that diplomacy
is needed to resolve the conflict
it doesn't make sense to resolve this
conflict militarily what we need now is
a diplomatic solution and that's what
we're striving for in coordination with
our international partners
we hope the discussions between ukraine
and russia will yield solutions and that
we can find a way to help us get out of
this situation
in washington that commitment to keeping
up diplomatic and economic pressure was
echoed by u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken
i am convinced that
we will see
a strategic defeat
of
president putin the propositions he's
put forward
will accomplish this by backing
ukrainians
in their fight
by remaining united in holding russia
accountable
through the devastating sanctions the
diplomatic isolation and other measures
and we've already seen that russia has
failed in its chief objectives
it's not been able to hold ukraine
it's not going to be able to hold
ukraine in the long term again no matter
what the tactical victories it may
achieve are
a discussion among western allies over
how to indirectly provide ukraine with
fighter jets has been overshadowed by
concerns that any overt military support
could raise the risk of a wider conflict
native secretary general jens
stoltzenberg cautioning against anything
that could escalate the war
nato has a responsibility to ensure that
this conflict does not escalate beyond
ukraine
because this would be even more
dangerous
destructive
and deadly
for ukraine and for all of us
i'm pleased to be joined now by wesley
clark he is a retired four-star general
of the us army and former nato supreme
allied commander in europe a very warm
welcome to the day sir um 23 years ago
in march 1999 nato under your command
intervened in kosovo when you look at
the refugees fleeing ukraine you look at
these long lines arriving in germany in
poland does that bring back memories
from those times
yes it does
back then in kosovo nato intervened now
in ukraine as we've heard nato saying
that it's best to stay out how do you
explain that to a ukrainian family that
is hiding in a bomb shelter
it's inexplicable to the canyon family
in a bomb shelter i understand what the
nato secretary general is saying
he's a he's a superb leader and um and
uh he's done an excellent job with nato
but the truth is that nato has to come
to terms and the united states has to
come to terms with the implications of
what this aggression means by russia
directed against ukraine
the any negotiations will be determined
by the outcome on the ground the outcome
on the ground is determined by the
resistance of the ukrainians the
russians have proven themselves a
relatively inept force
and i would remind our all of our
european listeners that escalation by mr
putin is not solely under the control of
nato no matter what nato does or doesn't
do mr putin may decide to escalate so
it's imperative that we sustain the
ukrainian forces in the fight
the russian forces are defeatable on the
battlefield and if they aren't as
secretary blinken has said russia can
face a strategic defeat over the midterm
from this and what does that actually
look like in practical terms sustaining
ukrainian forces
that means providing them javelins
stingers and as much
anti-air and air support as is feasible
to do so do you support a no-fly zone in
ukraine
no no you can't do a no-fly zone because
legally all the aficionados if they know
everything about air power say you can't
do it legally it could have been done
before russia attacked but at that point
the nations of the world were not ready
to believe that russia would attack now
it's not possible to do a legalistic
no-fly zone however air support can be
provided by nations who are willing to
go in these airspace this airspace does
not belong to russia i want to remind
your listeners that this is ukrainian
airspace and it's the president of
ukraine appealing for international
support
so uh nations should think about this if
their nation is under assault
they want international support it's
their nation so i i give a lot of
credence and a lot of credit to
president zielinski he's proved to be a
very courageous leader and i think the
nations of the west
have to find ways to support ukraine
well by nato sending in air power that
would mean u.s aircraft would be would
be need excuse me would need to be ready
to shoot down russian planes
i'm not going to get into the dispute
about whether u.s aircraft shoot down
russian planes wave at russian planes or
avoid russian planes this is for the
president of the united states and the
official leaders to decide upon and
determine how to proceed what i will say
is that the future of the west
determines is determined in large part
by what happens in this conflict in
ukraine it is in the interest of every
country in the west to support ukraine
on the ground how we're doing that
that's up to the leadership
and uh there's no point in and someone
like me who doesn't have access to the
real-time intelligence trying to
prescribe a military plan to military
leaders who are under a national
political authorities they have to know
how to do that when i was in uniform i
did
but surely sending an air power i just
want to come back to this point that
would mean um conflict i mean it would
mean that
the united states and nato allies would
have to be ready to go head-to-head with
russian planes and surely that would be
an escalation that could lead to putin
who has threatened who has put his
nuclear forces on high alert
to come back in a way that it's no
exaggeration could say could lead to
world war iii
let me ask you this question
if after putin has digested ukraine he
decides that he wants to finish his
political objective by rolling nato back
out of the other countries of eastern
europe who are now hosting nato troops
do we at that point say oh my goodness
since you might have nuclear weapons
against us we'll surrender what do we do
then
how likely do you think that would be
that he would invade
nato allied countries you and our nation
you and our national leaders have to
realize this putin's objectives are not
limited to ukraine
this is about rolling back the
westernization the rule of law the
international order in europe and the
rest of the world this is simply the
first battle
it is the easiest of the battles to
fight if our nations are unified and can
face reality in this if we fall back
and are intimidated by mr putin's threat
of nuclear weapons if there's nothing we
can do to help ukraine then um we'll be
dealing with the next crisis on nato's
territory itself
so what do you think mr putin has in his
sights are we talking about nato allied
states that you think he would intervene
in
certainly if you talk to the nations in
eastern europe they'll tell you
precisely what their fears are
from as long as i've dealt with the
russians in the post-cold war period
they've always believed that the baltic
states belong to them
and so does that thing think
do you think that russia is currently
winning on the ground in ukraine
russia's not winning on the ground it's
right now
uh check made it on the ground or at
least checked on the ground by poor
logistics communications and the stiff
resistance of the ukrainians
but
it could change the russians uh have no
regard for civilian casualties they do
have a lot of heavy firepower
and they do have an air force that could
be more uh deeply engaged today they're
bombing civilian targets in mario opal
i'm convinced mr putin's got an eye on
the international criminal court he's
trying to steal ukraine
as quietly and quickly as he can using
the threat of nuclear weapons but he
will use massive firepower if necessary
clearly
quietly i want to ask you how surprised
you were by the determination
of ukraine's army and its citizens in
pushing back against this invasion
i wasn't surprised by the ukraine's
determination or their army's
effectiveness but over there many years
however i will tell you this i was
surprised by the ineffectiveness of the
russian military
all right that was retired u.s general
wesley clark i want to thank you so much
sir for joining me here on the day
thank you very much
good interview thank you
we go now we'd like to turn now to
lieutenant general ben hodges he's a
retired u.s army officer and the former
commander of u.s forces in europe and he
joins us from frankfurt germany a very
good day sir so good of you to make some
time out
to speak to us why is sending weapons
into ukraine acceptable but sending
fighter jets untenable according to the
pentagon
yeah i completely disagree
with this decision
by the pentagon or the announcement if
that's the case i'm not sure that the
book is closed on this
um
i love the initiative by poland
to give capability that ukrainians need
so they can defend themselves
i'm sure it's more complicated
underneath than it seems
and that i'm willing to bet that we're
going to eventually get there
but
to the point of your question
i i would not make the difference that
you know providing aircraft is bad but
providing javelin is good or acceptable
so
i hope that we get this fixed very
quickly
um would you be in favor of nato
intervening or enforcing a no-fly zone
over ukraine as the ukrainians have been
pleading nato to do
well
for sure we cannot repeat what we did at
srebrenica in 1995 where
european soldiers under u.n mandate
stood outside the city while 8 000
bosnian men and boys were murdered by a
republican cersei foreign forces so we
can we can't do
that
we're watching deliberate murder of
ukrainian citizens every single day
because they're being targeted by
russian forces still this is not
inconsequential if nato gets inside
ukrainian airspace and on the ground in
ukraine that that potentially changes
the nature of what's going on here for
sure nato air forces would destroy
russian air forces but the bigger point
is what are the implications and and we
want to preserve the unity of the
alliance so this is not a decision to be
taken alone by the united states i do
think it's worth considering though
most of the damage that's being done in
the cities is not by the russian air
force it's being done by uh systems on
the ground missiles rockets artillery
fired from russian units inside ukraine
and also inside russia and by the black
sea fleet what can we do to help ukraine
destroy those anti-ship capability more
intelligence longer range systems
where ukrainians can destroy the source
of this damage
so how long do you think that the that
ukraine's army could withstand this
russian onslaught do you think that the
longer this war goes on the harder it
will be for russia to win it or the more
difficult it will be for ukraine to
stand its ground
now absolutely ukraine um uh is going to
win this uh russia is not going to get
into kyiv uh the russia has made the
decision to transition to attrition
warfare and to do that you have to have
time you have to have unlimited
ammunition and you have to have
unlimited manpower and russia has none
of those three the sanctions are going
to begin to take a real effect in the
next few weeks
and that's going to affect their their
time as well as their population
they do not have unlimited ammunition
we're already hearing reports of
shortages of some key munitions again
sanctions help here and they have a
manpower problem now they've already
stopped the departure of some troops who
are due to end their conscription and
they're trying to recruit mercenaries
from syria
so
this manpower problem is big for them
whereas the logistical effort
from the west for ukraine is only just
now picking up speed so i think actually
time is on the side of ukraine but the
ukrainians are outgunned and outnumbered
i mean how can they possibly win this
actually actually they're not
outnumbered uh there's more than 200 000
troops in ukraine's land forces and then
you've got a very large territorial
force and then we've seen very clearly
that the um ukrainian population is
willing to fight to to do things
russia does not have that many soldiers
inside inside ukraine so there is no
they're not outnumbered clearly the
russians have the advantage from sea
power and at this point air power
but they have not demonstrated uh the
overwhelming air power superiority that
frankly i would have expected so i think
that in this case because the logistics
is going to improve
is improving for the ukrainians and it
only gets more difficult for the
russians
i think that ukraine as long as the west
sticks together and continues to support
i think ukraine has a chance to to come
out of this uh on the right side
and in conclusion sir i i just want to
ask you
should the u.s engage with russia should
the u.s engage directly with the kremlin
to stop this bloodshed
well here's what we should be doing
on april the 1st one april 130 000 young
russian men 19 and 20 years old have to
report for duty at conscription centers
it's the scheduled next wave of
conscription that means 130 000 families
are about to send their son and brother
off to become cannon fodder as privates
in the russian army to fight in a war of
slavs against lives
i think if we could somehow reach even a
third of those families and that they've
refused to send their son to
conscription
that would be like an earthquake inside
russia and that this is what we need is
pressure organic pressure from inside
russia this is how this comes to a
conclusion
retired lieutenant general ben hodges
the former commander of u.s forces in
europe sir thank you for your time
oh thank you for the privilege
you